Transcriber: Shaimaa Yahia
المدقّق: Asala ALmasry
السلام عليكم.
قبل أن أبدأ.
إذا سألتكم عن التطوع، ماذا ستقولون لي؟
لنرى.
ما هو التطوع؟
سأسألكم ثم تجيبونني برأيكم.
تفضل.
صح.
تطوع؟
عطاء.
هل من الممكن أن يكون التطوع بالإجبار؟
هل يوجد من يجبرك على التطوع؟
لا.
بالنسبة لي كلمة تطوع هي كلمة،
لكن يندرج تحتها سرد كبير،
لو دققنا فيها...
نجد التغيير من أولوياتك.
أنا كيف... أساعد؟
كيف أحاول؟ كيف أثابر؟
كيف أعطي فقط
لأنه لا أحد أجبرني على هذا الشيء...
أبداً.
كم متطوع حاضر معنا  في القاعة؟
كم  عدد المتطوعين؟
ارفعوا أيديكم.
كم شخص منكم تطوع في السابق؟
تقريبًا الجميع، وهذا هو الأساس .
أنا أريد أن أتطوع.
التطوع شيء فيكم أنتم.
أنا فصلت حياتي، عملي،
ساعات من حياتي لأني أريد أن أساعد
أريد أن أبادر أريد أن أعطي.
فهنا تبدأ ترتيب الأولويات، والمسؤوليات
كما تريدون.
سافرنا إلى “أفريقيا“،
و“بورما“، والحدود عند أماكن حرب،
يوجد أماكن عدم، ويوجد أماكن مجاعة، ويوجد
أماكن جوع،
أماكن مرض.
بصفة شخصية أو بصفة طبية، أريد أن أساعد
أريد أن أعطي.
ما الذي يجبرني؟ هل يوجد أي شيء يجبرني؟
لا
أول شيء عليك أن تقنع أهلك، هذا رقم واحد.
رقم اثنين: عندما ترى العطاء في أول بذرة
أنت زرعتها
تأتيك بعد ذلك ردود الأفعال، والدعوات،
والسعادة التي تراها في عيون الآخرين.
تقول الحمد الله أنني تطوعت، الحمد لله
أنني ساعدت الحمد لله أنني أعطيت.
كان هذا هو الأساس.
أنا “ديمة”
ما الذي يجعلني أستمر؟
لماذا أنا مستمرة إلى الآن؟
لماذا أريد أن أساعد دائمًا؟
سأروي لكم قصة حدثت لي أنا شخصيًا،
في بعض الأوقات تظهر الصعوبات في حياتكم
التطوعية، لأن هذا ليس بعمل، ليس بمهنة
ليس بشيء تأخذ عليه مكافأة مادية،
أو حتى قبل أن يكون هذا ضمن برنامج
“الرؤية”، وأنا أكثر واحدة سعيدة في الدنيا
حيث سيصبح التطوع من الضروريات
في “الرؤية” عام 2030
التي تم طرحها في البلد عندنا، الحمد الله
هذه نعمة كبيرة.
لأنه أصبح كل شخص...
ممكن أوقات...
الغصب يكون مفيد.
لأنه فتح أبواب لناس لم يخطر ببالها
أن تتطوع وتطوعت.
أنا قدمت في دراسات عليا وقُبلت.
وكان ضمن اللجنة التي عقدت لي المقابلة
في الدراسات العليا خمسة أطباء.
هذان الاثنان، في اثنين أطلق عليهم
“سين” من الناس.
واحد منهم رسّبني، لكني نجحت بعد ذلك.
ولكن كوني رسبت...
لماذا؟ لأنهم قالوا أنتِ يا “ديمة”،
التطوع أولوياتك أنتِ جئت لكي تدرسين.
إن تدرسين توقفين عن التطوع.
هذا الكلام ما له دخل بالنسبة لي،
جهزت نفسي، المطلوب مني أن أقدم الأشياء
التي يجب أن أقدمها،
أنجح، أختبر،
أقدم كل شيء وأنفذه؛ ما لأحد دخل بأشياء
أخرى.
التطوع هو أنا الآن.
لا أحد يحق له أن يوقفك عن... طموح، عن فكر،
عن هوية صارت “ديمة” تساوي تطوع،
فما لأحد حق.
فلا توقفون سقف الطموح أو سقف
التطوع أبدًا.
لأننا في التطوع ليس لدينا سقف كفاية،
سقفنا غير منته، غير... ما له حد.
دائمًا   لا تتوقفوا.
بعدها رسبت، ونجحوني، وطلبت نقاش طويل،
ومرت،
وربي ما يضيع حق.
بعد أن أنهيت الدراسات العليا من نفس
اللجنة،
قابلني شخص في اللجنة نفسها،
كان سبب القبول أن “ديمة” كانت تطوع،
و“ديمة” لها أعمال إنسانية،
وتم قبولي في قسم
“Medical Compromised Patients”
لمن لديهم أمراض
ليس في الأسنان فقط، في مجال الأسنان،
في المستشفيات.
أشتغل الآن في قسم للأمراض
لمرضى زراعة الأعضاء، والسرطانات،
والأمراض المستعصية.
وظفوني في هذا القسم بسبب عملي في التطوع،
أو لما قمت به.
فالفكرة هي ألا تتوقفوا.
أنا جاءتني أيام كنت أرجع البيت أصيح.
هل من المعقول أن يحدث هذا؟
ثم قلت: أكيد يوجد شيء ربي كاتبه لي.
وأنا كل يوم أنام وأقوم عمري ما أشيل
هم بكرة.
أعلم أن ربي كاتب لي رزق، وتوفيق
وهذا ما يجب أن تؤمنوا به،
تعطي باليمين يأتيك باليسار،
تعطي بظهر الغيب ربي سيوفقك ويفتحها بوجهك،
يفتح أبواب بوجهك إلى يوم الدين
لن تدري بها.
هذه النقاط المهمة.
ما الذي يدفعني للاستمرار؟
الأعداد التي في الصور، المتطوعون القادمون.
بدل المرة ألف مرة، ما في شيء يوقفهم،
في رمضان لم نفطر ولا يوم مع أهلنا
هذا داخل البلد، خارج البلد نشتغل،
ونذهب في الصباح من الساعة... أحياناً خمسة
الفجر إلى الساعة الثانية بالليل
الله يكرمكم مجاري يدخل فيها أمراض، تعب،
أصبت بكورونا، وأنا في “تنزانيا”
مرضت سبعة أيام، وبلغت الحرارة 40 ونصف.
هل تظنون أني توقفت؟
لا.
مستمرة، والمكتوب مكتوب.
وإن شاء الله...
لا أشعر بالخوف، وسأستمر دائمًا،
ولن أتوقف أبدًا.
لا تضعوا حد لهذا الموضوع أبدًا، هذا الشيء
يجعلكم تستمرون دائمًا.
ودائمًا عندي نقطة مهمة في هذه الأشياء،
سأروي لكم قصة، ربما تكون هذه أول مرة
أتكلم فيها عن هذه التفاصيل
ترددت مليون مرة اليوم،
هل أرويها لكم أم لا.
لكن سأرويها.
حدثت لي قصة في أول رحلة،
لأن عندنا في التطوع يوجد تصوير،
أوقات يقول لك لا تصور، حرام،
لكن أوقات تحتاج صور لكي توصل رسالة،
وهذا ما حدث.
يوجد أشياء نريدكم أن ترونها،
لأنه لن ترونها إذا ما صورنا.
ليس الغرض أن نسوّق مستغلين ضعف الآخرين
أو حاجتهم، لاء.
عندما ولدت عندي تشوه خلقي في وجهي،
متعايشة معه من زمان، عمره ما وقفني،
كان بالنسبة لي أتوقع،
توقيع، هوية، هذه أنا.
كان معنا أحد الأشخاص في رحلة من الرحلات
في الحدود،
كان يوجد ولد أهله...
كان من اللاجئين السوريين.
أهله أتذكر...حدث تفجير وتوفوا الأهل،
وأمه كانت مبتورة الساقين.
وكانت قصة دمار بشكل،
يعني لا في أي مشابه ولا مقارنة بأي شيء
مررت به.
أنا واحدة الحمد لله ربي رزقني أهل متعلمين،
مرتاحين ربها يسر لها الأمور،
واستمرت، وكل شيء كان...
رغم إني يمكن خضعت لإجراء 27 عملية،
منذ كنت صغيرة إلى قبل ثلاث سنوات،
هل تظنون أن أتوقف؟
أبدًا بالعكس.
جاء هذا الشخص قال لي “ديمة” أنا أريد...
دي أول رحلة تطوعية لي مستحيل أنساها،
مسكني على جنب، وقال نريد أن تقولي للولد:
إن أنا حاسة فيك
وانظر إلى وجهي،
أريدك... تكون...
أمم لا يضيق صدرك لأنه أهلك هكذا
أنت كمان -محروق كان هو الولد-
هل قارن الحرق بالقصة التي حدثت؟،أو بالشيء
الذي أنا فيه؟ لاء طبعا
قُلت OK.
جاء اللقاء ما تكلمت أبداً ولا قُلت
ولا كلمة؛
فتفاجأ الرجال كيف! يوم خلصت بعمرك للتاجر
مشاعر الآخرين لأن هذا عيب.
هذه القصة مستحيل أنساها لأنه لا تسمحوا
لأحد أن يتاجر بعواطفكم، أو عواطف الآخرين.
دائمًا يكون لكم رأي، لأني أنا كان ممكن
أسكت أقول أول مرة، أول فرصة لي بتكلم.
لكن لا.
دائمًا يكون رأيكم لأنفسكم
لا أحد يتاجر بكم، هذه أهم النقاط.
هل أنتم تساعدون بعملكم التطوعي؟
هل يوجد شيء يتغير؟
هل يحدث شيء عندما تتطوع؟
أنتم الآن المتطوعين، هل أنجزتم شيء؟
هل تشعرون أنكم تفعلون شيء؟
نعم!
هل ممكن كان يصير هذا اللقاء بدون متطوعين؟
مستحيل.
التطوع شيء كبير... شيء...
تساعد... التطوع به
طبي، صحي،
توعوي، مجتمعي، من وإلى، ما له حد.
اختار أنت أين تريد أن تكون
وستجد نفسك، لكن اعرف إلى أين ستذهب.
عندنا مبادرة كانت قبل فترة.
كان في أمس كلام ذكرني بعلاقة الجار،
من أستاذ فاضل،
أيام كورونا لما حدث عندنا الحجر الكلي.
كان عندنا 24 ساعة ما كان حدا يطلع
من البيت،
ثم سمحوا بأخذ ساعة على أن تطلع
في نطاق ضيق.
هذه كانت أول مرة أتوقع للحارات...
تمشون في الحارة
تشوفون الناس معكم،
هل عمركم شفتم أماكن الحارة؟
لا.
أنشأنا صندوق،
تم تبنيه من... منظمة،
من جهة رسمية،
وكانت الفكرة أن “سابع جار”
جار يُهدي جاره .
وبدأت الفكرة من “الرياض” من “الدرعية”
إلى كل “السعودية”،
انطلقت ووصلت إلى كل أنحاء المملكة.
ومن هذه الفكرة أحيينا سُنة
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم،
واستفدنا من الجائحة؛ جعلتنا نعرف الجار،
نحب الجار، نسأل عن بعض، خاف على بعض.
كل ما أريد قوله لكم:
من ناحية أن أنا “ديمة” (ضوضاء)
ماذا علمني التطوع؟
إني دائمًا أقول لكم إن كل شيء يبدأ بخطوة،
فاجعل تلك الخطوة
خطوة خير.